Bring It On
hello everyone and welcome back to binge
battle what an exciting episode we have
for you all here at Rotten Tomatoes
because we're talking about the best TV
of 2022 and to do that we have two
expert panelists who are not only Great
Debaters of all things entertainment
they also happen to be in the big screen
well I mean they're up on the big screen
they're in a movie that's touring
festivals and cleaning up a lot of
awards called Always Wella so we'll talk
about that at the end of the show in the
meantime there's a lot of Television
that came out this past year and we're
here to celebrate the highs the lows the
surprises the twists the turns all that
good stuff with some of our favorite
shows from streaming services and
networking cable as well so my name is
Mark Ellis we're about to get set before
I introduce your guest here today I will
remind you that as always here on binge
battle there's going to be some spoilers
so the alert is in session particularly
for one of the waiter rounds where we
will be talking about our favorite
moments from TV shows of 2022. So if you
haven't seen a particular show you can
still enjoy this episode but if we bring
up a show you haven't seen yet maybe
just hit that mute button for a little
bit until we get to the next topic we
are set for at least four rounds
possibly a tie breaking fifth round and
given the two competitors we have here
today I imagine it's going to come right
down to the wire introducing first she
is a returning favorite here to the show
you know her as one of the creators of
the World Girls Empire they have a
calendar you can order right now she
also does her Daily Show live at the
Roxy and one of the stars of always Loa
it's Roxy Strayer welcome back home you
make me sound so much cooler than I am
Mark and I really appreciate that thanks
this is my favorite thing to do you know
I'm obsessed with TV this is like
Sophie's Choice times 10 for me today
but I'm excited to talk about it I know
and and I don't want to get you know too
personal but I'm just curious because
like you hear all the things you're
doing in the world and entertaining the
masses how do you find the time to watch
as much TV because I know that you're
you're basically like me you're just a
couch potato you may be a better you
know looking Couch Potato than the guy
talking right now but you still love
sitting down and watching TV how do you
find the time listen you're still a
sweet potato I'm a yellow potato there's
just different kind of potatoes for
people I have watched 115 Series this
year so far
and I think I attribute that to being
lonely and single so you know it's just
things to really aspire to me your
opponent today also has a lovely pup
named Snickers you also know him from
his wonderful performance in always well
again it's making the festival runs
we'll talk about that at the end of the
show he also is a wonderful actor in
other projects as well you've seen them
host you've seen them coming you've seen
them pundit on things like his Action
Army platform it's Andrew Guy what is up
I'm Gonna Leave Roxy's watched a hundred
and how many series like I already knew
you were the queen of Television I was
already incredibly intimidated but yeah
wow I've watched maybe I've probably
watched like 50s Series this year though
I've watched a ton of TV but that's
still like a third of what rocks has
watched yeah 50 setting the bar pretty
high and then Roxy just comes in and you
know I mean I and I know Roxy watches a
lot of live sports too and so it's we
got some good viewers of TV here and
again this is everything from streaming
shows you may have watched on a device
like your phone all the way up to
whoever's got those huge TVs that are
100 inches maybe even a projection TV
that you watch your favorite streaming
service or network or cable show on
we're talking about all of it
um Andrew you and Snickers when you guys
are home and you're watching TV what is
the setup there is it a giant TV are you
more of like I watch stuff on my phone
when I'm traveling kind of guy I am
obsessed with Black Friday like it's
like the one time of year I like plan
all year long for that one day and then
like the Monday and the Friday and I
just spend a lot of money so I think it
was last year I bought like a nice big
TV for our apartment it's like the first
time I've bought my own big TV like I
always wanted one as a kid and now that
I'm old I did it and so I sit there with
my heated blanket because it's freezing
it's in the 50s now in La I've got a
sweater on and sticker sits right next
to me and he watches sometimes he
watches sometimes but if it gets
stressful he leaves the room he doesn't
like stressful shows yeah it's just
about that time in our lovely city of
Southern California that I start
ordering the thermal stocks for a for a
Long Winter that could get down to dare
I say 49 degrees so here we go with
binge battle as a friendly reminder to
everybody for all the latest in the
world of TV movies and everything in
between you can head over to
rottentomatoes.com a lot of good
articles listicles breaking news all
that good stuff right there at
rottentomatoes.com and with that we are
going to get kicked off with the shows
that we loved of 2022 topic number one
in round number one is the best drama
what was the best drama of 2022 Andrew
Guy you have the honor at your ready sir
one minute on the clock so I'm gonna go
with the best drama being the bear that
came out on Hulu I mean it's one of
those shows especially because I was a
person that worked in restaurants for
almost a decade that I felt so
viscerally invested in every single
episode it gave me such anxiety I think
the second to last episode is one of the
greatest pieces of Television I've ever
seen it's an a 19 minute one shot which
I think is such an accomplishment in and
of itself but also what it does for the
drama of like heightening the stakes
from that show the performances all
throughout are great and what I think I
love so much is that it's not really
about a whole lot right it's about grief
it's about someone trying to deal with
the grief of losing a family member but
also kind of finding their way in life
it's just like such a beautiful Slice of
Life that I feel like is so incredibly
relatable and I think that that's
something that's really important when
you're watching dramas out there it
makes you laugh it makes you cry it
stresses you out but really at the end
of the day you could be any of these
characters and that's why for me
watching the bear I was just blown away
not every you know not only from the
technical standpoint from the acting but
also just like the wonderful
storytelling I mean you get an eight
minute monologue in the serious finale I
mean come on yeah it's a lot of
memorizing
I was like I'm gonna practice this
monologue I'm gonna learn it and then I
looked at it I was like there's no way
I'm gonna ever do this monologue so
that's that yeah I'm more of AI I'm not
more of a riff guy so let's go to uh
Roxy's dryer here for your best drama
Andrew setting the bar pretty high with
the bear I'm gonna try to keep it under
eight minutes although I'm still trying
to impress Andrew with this monologue I
think that it is so abundantly clear
that the number one best drama of the
year is Severance the reason for that is
because it hit us like a ton of bricks
out of nowhere I think that nobody was
expecting Ben Stiller to be able to
create something that like hit us all in
a way that just you you couldn't
conceptualize what was going on even
you're watching something that you can't
even explain but you are glued to the
screen I think that the the acting the
performances are the best of the year
but it's really about the story this is
what sells it us trying to question our
own selves if I could have an any and an
Audi if I could set operate my work from
my life would I do that and what would
that look like and I know for a fact if
you are watching this there is a chance
that you would you would separate that
and now we're watching what that would
actually look like and it's it's causing
us to actually question our own
realities and best television does that
yeah it's interesting you guys both
pictures first of all that are Super
Fresh on the Tomato Meter the Bear in
fact is a hundred percent Severance 97
so they're both just crushing it with
with critics and audiences alike and you
also chose shows that you know it's best
drama really focusing here on Grief and
how one copes with grief how you get
through it various tactics to do that
maybe you take over a restaurant and you
reinvent the menu or you just get a
couple chords up there in your brain
chop so let's go back to Andrew Guy for
your rebuttal this round is 30 seconds
or less well you see the bear has a
hundred percent on Rotten Tomatoes and
uh Severance only has a 90s so I think
one of the things that Roxy touched on
and don't get me wrong I absolutely
loved Severance Ellis you're the person
that sold me on this show I think the
reason for me it didn't actually go to
the best drama for me personally was
because I did feel like it is so high
concept it is so hard to actually relate
to these people and what they're going
through and while I do agree that the
acting is phenomenal the storytelling is
absolutely incredible when I look at
like a nitty-gritty cut and dry just
like a drama because I do believe that
Severance is a sci-fi thriller and it is
drama I I completely agree that it is
available to be in this category but I
do think that there's so much going on
that it almost distracts from just the
heart of interpersonal relationships and
again just being in the muck of life
even though I do understand that
Severance deals a lot with the everyday
muck of life it really is one big Mark
isn't it we're all just trying to get
through it and uh you know you think
about something like the bear and how
easily relatable it is uh Roxy Andrew
makes an interesting point that
Severance maybe we can't relate to that
technology because it's not readily
available but we still feel like we know
these people a little bit right we can't
relate yet Mark we don't know what the
world looks like to tomorrow I'm like
Drew I worked at a restaurant for seven
years I loved the bear it has my heart
you know whose heart it probably doesn't
have people who don't know what it's
like to sip out of a tupperware full of
water I think that this is such an
incredible show if you can relate to it
but otherwise parts of it are very
lackluster I'm actually more excited for
season two of The Bear knowing the
premise going in than I was for season
one because I want to see what he's able
to make of himself in season two and
season one there was a lot of sitting
around a lot of waiting I also think
that star power is on our side with
Severance I cannot believe we had this
show it's just like kind of a random
Apple TV show with Christopher Walken
with John Turturro I mean the fact that
we are watching like these massive stars
just pop in and out of TV shows in 2022
it is so cool and while it is high
concept it stuck The Landing in a way
that everybody understood and when
you're able to do that at the end of a
show I think that it just makes the
entire thing worthwhile it was certainly
worthwhile although it didn't make me
quite as hungry as the bear did I've
been scouring SoCal for the best of time
beef sandwich Andrew you and I can
debate that off camera right now it is
your final statement sir my final
statement is going to be this the bear
does not have that star power it does I
mean Jeremy Allen White is a guy that a
lot of people are like who is he again I
recognize him from that other show right
but that other show was really more
about William H Macy I think why this
show is the best drama of the year is
because it relies solely on the writing
the way that it shot and the acting no
big names no Ben Stiller no apple I mean
it's also on Hulu right Hulu I feel like
if you are like Roxy and I you recognize
that Hulu puts out a lot of great
television content but I still feel like
it's kind of lower on the totem pole
than something like Apple TV plus I
think that this is a Cinderella Story
That's screamed to the top it's got a
hundred percent of Rotten Tomatoes as
you said Mark and I think it's for a
reason now while I understand it might
not be relatable for people that didn't
work in restaurants being being with
someone my partner who's never worked in
a restaurant I think she got it finally
and that's something that you never you
always hear that everyone needs to work
in a restaurant once in their life the
bear is kind of at least like a crash
course for people that will never do it
uh yeah and I would count myself amongst
those ranks because even though I've
never worked at a restaurant I've been
in some pressure situations in close
quarters like the bear portrays in the
kitchen and so it's like oh yeah I kind
of know what that feels like Roxy you
get to close out round number one in
support of the Dan Erickson created Ben
Stiller directed Severance treat your
servers well everybody
the thing about Severance is that I
don't just think that it is the best
show of this year I think it's the best
first season of any show we've had at
this decade it does such an unbelievable
job of convincing you to care about
these people that were only spending
half an amount of time with we don't
know if their Audis are actually good
people and we just have to trust that we
want these people to win based on their
innies the bear is great and I think
it's going to get better as it goes I
don't know that any season of severance
could possibly top what they gave to us
in season one it was certainly a tough
fact to follow really for both shows and
so it's an interesting point because
because we asked for best drama and
Severance does you know delve into some
sci-fi some Twilight Zony horror sort of
Vibes but if you were just to find these
two shows at Blockbuster Video back in
the day I think we'd both be wandering
towards the drama section I love how
they both deal with some of the same
issues in very different ways and with
very different contexts great acting
great writing across the board Andrew I
have good news for you your show won the
Tomato Meter battle but I feel like
here's the thing I feel like Severance
just left us where we need to get to
season two like right now where the bear
I was thrilled to watch it but after it
ended I was like good this is over I can
run out and grab an Italian beef
sandwich myself then I can come back and
get ready for season two so by the
slimmest of margins y'all pick my two
favorite shows of the year just so you
know I'm going with Severance and the
point goes to Roxy stryer in round
number one but Andrew's gonna have to
dust himself off and get right back in
the ball game came here because we're on
to round two where our topic is the best
comedy what was the best comedy of 2022
Roxy stryer gets to kick us off with a
one-nothing lead I don't think enough
people are acknowledging that we have
our current day Parks and Rec our
current day the office we have Abbott
Elementary this show is laugh out loud
funny start to finish every single
episode doesn't miss uh season two is
just as good if not better than season
one I cannot wait to watch this when it
airs if if I have 15 things on my DVR do
people have DVRs anymore whatever you
know what I mean on my queue this is the
first thing that I'm watching because I
need it I feel like this show came out
of time in which we as a society are in
trouble and it is sad out there and this
show is like you know what's happening
out there we don't care this is a small
show that takes place in a school and we
are going to just show you how funny it
can be when you go to a situational
comedy setting and it's a workplace
comedy but it's a school in Philadelphia
East Coast 5 this is so good so good
Andrew I'm before I get your answer here
it's interesting that Roxy picks Abbott
Elementary that's a network show yet we
still feel like network shows now are
the little show that could versus some
of the streaming Giants that put out
quality content so now Andrew guy has
his opening statement for what show
uh well I do love Albert Elementary but
I'm actually gonna have to go with
Abbott Elementary uh this is the best
show that's on TV comedy-wise period
it's Parks and Rec of our general no
okay I'm not going to repeat everything
that Roxy said but I will go and hop on
the bandwagon of the office right like
we never thought we could ever replicate
the office and I think when the office
came it was kind of like us leaving the
the 90s and 2000s and now like that
office workplace comedy was the thing
then but now like we're getting into
paying attention to real culture and
what's going on in the world and this
being in a school and being a hilarious
comedy Roxy's 100 correct it never
misses but it's also so poignant it is
so on top of these socio-political
issues that teachers deal with every
single day I mean my partner is getting
her PhD in education policy she used to
be a teacher she used to be a teacher at
a lower income school you know this is
exactly hitting all those Nails on the
head not only being hilarious but also
being incredibly heartwarming and
bringing attention to things that need
to be paid attention to in the world
like we've been talking about how
teachers are underpaid since all of us
were in school in elementary school and
it's only gotten worse over that time
period I won't say how many years it's
been I believe Abbott Elementary is the
best thing on television right now
comedy-wise because it's like it's like
this is us except for you only cry a
little bit and you laugh a lot it's like
it switches it yeah you can turn up the
tear duct Factory that yeah this is us
gave us all in Abbott Elementary
um you all both picked the same show
different styles of arguing but it's a
99 Tomato Meter winner right now so you
both have a lot of momentum we're going
back to Roxy stryer here for your
rebuttal against Andrews pick Abbott
Elementary yeah I see what you're saying
about Abbott Elementary but I really
feel like it must be Abbott Elementary
I haven't said that a network show is
the funniest show on TV in 15 years I
mean it's crazy how captivating this
show is it won three Emmys this year it
deserved all three of them if not more
one of the cool things about this show
too is that I don't know who my favorite
character is with comedies I latch on to
somebody really quick but because I love
all of them so much I go back and forth
per episode they do a really great job
of focusing on somebody else and letting
somebody else shine week to week and it
also has maybe the greatest will they
won't they relationship since Ross and
Rachel Janine and Greg like are they
going to are they not going to we know
they are but when I'm a lover of love a
shipper ship so just having that to
Anchor me too I'm like thank you Abbott
Elementary I think I was a little more
Ross and Rachel than Jim and Pam so I'll
I'll give you that you're still in the
whole game here
um let's go to Andrew Guy where do you
stand on Rawson right now what were you
just talking about
uh I mean I'm gonna just go to the
characters because these are all people
that I didn't really know who any of
them were before watching this show and
I've fallen so in love with every single
person I completely agree with what Rox
is saying about your favorite except for
I don't think my favorite is ever Keen
to Brunson even though I think she's
perfect in the show I think she does an
incredible job writing it but she's kind
of like that she's she's kind of like
Ross you're always like what are you
doing stop being so annoying but you
kind of uh empathize with her I
absolutely love her but when you look at
Barbara when you look at Shirley Ralph
you know obviously winning that Emmy she
has done something that I think so many
actors want to do which is take that
stage presence that thing that she has
that big chewing up words and bringing
it to the small screen and going and
looking at her and be like oh my God
that is a thespian every single episode
I watch with her the way she takes her
time her presence when she has uh in her
scenes just a look on her face I am so
blown away by her every single episode
but like rock said Tyler James Williams
is amazing Ava Coleman is incredible uh
Janelle Jones uh or James excuse me like
every single character on the show is
wonderful and I think that is something
that is so hard to do and it's that
Insight that we always were wondering
what is going on in that teacher's
lounge when we were kids and now we we
get to see it in all of its Glory uh
Roxy Strayer you have the first final
statement stumping for Abbott Elementary
one of the reasons this show is not
being as widely loved and talked about
is because the marketing funds and I've
spoken about this actually here on this
show before were given to teachers
instead of actually marketing the show
to underfunded teachers that's where a
lot of the marketing budget went for the
show which just makes you love it even
more that the show is practicing what it
preaches uh and and there's actual heart
and soul to this show you're actually
watching people try their best at their
job it's not one of those comedies where
everybody sucks at what they do okay the
principal's awful lot what she does but
the teachers they're out there every day
trying and I I think that that's really
beautiful then that they're also trying
to support real world teachers it feels
authentic to the the struggles that a
lot of teachers in our country face
let's go to Andrew Guy we're talking
best comedies you both have Abbott
Elementary why is this the best show for
you it's because it is The Little Engine
That Could not only in terms of it being
a show that became one of the biggest
shows in the world winning all these
Awards but because I also think it's a
story for a creative artist in and of
themself like again you talk about
Barbara Cheryl Lee Ralph she's been
acting for like 50 years and now I'm
finally hearing who she is kinta Brunson
started on the internet right with
making these little blurbs on her
Instagram making these little comedy
videos and now she's winning Emmys on
the biggest show in America like this is
not only inspiring from watching it and
what they're doing for teachers out
there in the world you know these people
but also just from like a creative
standpoint as people all three of us
living in La trying to do what we want
to do that you know following our dreams
I think that's the other great thing
about this show is that these people
that are making this they really have
kind of been around either forever or
like built this incredible name for
themselves it makes you believe that you
can as well if you get all that out of a
comedy on network television I'm down
man well speak for yourself I already
followed my dream I'm about ready to
retire so this might be it for me and
one of the last judgments I get to make
is who gets the point for the best
comedy Andrew you just you you guys both
kind of got on that train where it's
just this this little Underdog show that
ended up going to the Emmys and and
winning and getting nominated for all
these Awards I like your sort of story
of where everybody started and where
they are now thanks to shows like Abbott
Elementary and so again they're two
great competitors they picked one great
show by the slim Vista margins Andrew
guy gets the point in round at number
two and that means that we are heading
to round at number three tied one to one
with we talk about the underdog shows
that we love what is the most underrated
show that is the topic in round number
three and Andrew Guy you have even the
score what is your most underrated show
of 2022. I hope you were happy when you
saw this everyone I I'm sure Roxy was uh
so my most underrated show period is
Love is Blind now you might be asking
yourself what the hell is this guy
talking about this is a stupid reality
dating show but that's exactly the point
anyone that watches Love is Blind loves
love is blind you either love to hate it
or you hate that you love it or you
actually love watching the way that
people date these interpersonal
relationships watching people actually
get to know each other without seeing
each other it is a fascinating social
experiment but the reason I say it's the
most underrated show is because it look
if I talk to someone about the bear or
Severance or succession I go hey have
you seen this like no I need to though
if you talk to anyone about love is
blind and they have like have you seen
love is one like no you can't I'm never
gonna what is wrong with you that show
is horrible I don't watch Trash like
that it's because it's underrated the
show is phenomenal it's one of the best
things I've ever seen it is the
universal language literally I've I
could go anywhere and talk about
television I've ever bring up Love is
Blind everyone in the room gets excited
except for the one guy that refuses to
watch it that's his fault and that would
probably be me but you have an
interesting angle here with your reality
show that will use reality in quotes but
it is that high concept sort of reality
where it might be the reality version of
something like Severance where it's this
interesting concept that might just be
enough to hook even the viewer who may
not think it's for them so let's go over
to Roxy streyer now what is your most
underrated show of this past year I'm
gonna get to Love is Blind in a minute
because that
but I
I valued here is a show that people
don't talk about anymore it had a little
buzz season one and then it really fell
off of people's radar for no reason and
that's Rami Romi is unbelievable it's
one of the funniest most poignant shows
on TV I don't know why it isn't getting
the love it deserves it's really truly a
a more of a message about who our
society is and how they don't know how
to pick their television and that's why
you guys need people like us to tell you
what's good because when you're out
you're not watching shows like Rami you
are doing yourself a disservice it's
about a Muslim man and I think that a
lot of people are like oh maybe I won't
be able to relate to this but it is so
relatable this is coming from a Jew and
he makes so much commentary about real
life things and he makes it funny in a
way that makes me know that Mark Ellis
has always been right about comedians
being able to make anything funny if
they do it in the right way we had
entire episode this season that had a
holocaust joke through line and again I
can say this because I'm Jewish it was
the funniest episode of TV of the year
and I was like how'd you do that how did
you do that you brilliant brilliant man
Rami is out of this world good and it is
a shame you're not watching it yeah Rama
used to have a very talented a comedian
in addition to creating this show and uh
yeah I mean it I think it there was
there was Emmys involved and there
there's Awards and then um maybe not
necessarily the buzz that we thought we
would have for this latest season but it
lived up to the expectations the fans of
the show had and that's a pretty high
bar so let's go back to you Andrew guy
tell me more about why folks like me
need to see Love is Blind well okay so
first of all I bet they've heard of it
which I think is good right because
Romney they may not have heard of that's
one of those like Niche shows that I
feel like People Like Us in this city
that watch a lot of TV are people that
know about it but I do think if you talk
to anyone about it they'll say it's a
great show right it's not underrated
whereas Love is Blind is constantly
there's Blasphemous statements all over
the Internet Twitter is always there's
listicles there's BuzzFeed articles
everyone's talking trash about love is
blind and the people that are on it but
look at the end of the day when you
watch TV you want to feel good about
yourself right you want to feel better
about yourself and what's a great way to
do that judge other people on television
that are doing reality dating so you
know what the other side of it is maybe
you need a little pick-me-up maybe
you've just had a rough day go watch
some love is blind you'll feel really
smart and you'll feel like you're just a
better person than a lot of them on
there even though you might not be you
get to judge and that's what reality
television is all about all right we do
love judging with our reality TV show
and we do love sort of getting on board
with these programs that maybe not
everybody's seen and we get to be the
friend that recommends it to everyone
else Roxy I have a feeling you were that
friend for a lot of people with Romney
oh I absolutely was but people don't
listen to me people do listen about love
is blind to the extent that it's number
one on the top 10 in Netflix every
single time it comes out we see it when
we're scrolling through everybody knows
that it exists 30 million people watch
the first season and the thing about
this show is I can't say one bad thing
about the show but season one
exceptional because we found true love
one of the greatest couples to ever come
out of TV in Lauren and Cam I like
follow them I actually like live by them
they are so cute together and you just
we're never going to get that again
because so many people found that this
show was so big they want to get famous
like that guy Andrew from the show
putting Visine in his eyes you guys saw
that Meme so that he could pretend he
was crying we're not getting that
quality of person that we got in season
one anymore and while the show is still
really good I think it's down here from
Hill downhill from here because there
are people that are coming on this that
want the fame because they know how big
the show is Rami barely anybody talking
about it we had one of the uh Hadid
sisters on it this year where is that no
PO nobody knows that even the two of the
most famous people are appearing on the
show and still nobody's talking about it
like What's it gonna take for us to get
people talking about Rami uh all you
have to do is actually watch it and then
you'll know how great it is but for some
reason I can't convince anybody all
right Andrew Roxy's having a tough time
convincing people to watch her show I'm
curious as your experience with Love is
Blind when you talk to folks who haven't
seen it yet if they're on board with it
because everybody hears the concept and
they're like oh that's pretty
interesting but in your final statement
you can you can either expound on that
you can say why it's better than Romney
you have the four sir okay so what I
will say is did you hear how passionate
Roxy was talking about love is blind
that's what this show can do for you it
can do this for you mark it did this for
you guys watching at home okay yes
season one 30 million people but since
season one because of what Roxy's
talking about I think less and less
people are akin to watching or checking
out love is blind however I do still
believe that even though a lot of people
are going on that show to get famous
they still get weeded out and there's
still people that are trying to fall in
love with one another not everyone on
the show is compatible and I'm sure a
lot of them are staying around because
they do want to try to get that Fame but
you still get to watch people try to
date and I I've been in a relationship
for a long time okay I miss watching
dating I want to be a fly on the wall
when I hear about my friends going on
first dates I get to do that with this
show I get to go out there and
vicariously live through these people
that are not just sitting with Snickers
watching movies every single night love
is blind is underrated because season
three is getting better and better it's
not running out rocks it's only going up
from here all right Andrew thinks that
the future is bright for Love is Blind
Roxy you have the final statement and
the final word in round three to use
Andrew's words against him people aren't
watching Hulu that the way way that we
were wishing they were and rami's on
Hulu and love is blind is on Netflix and
Netflix is the Behemoth that it is and
it recommends to you exactly what you
need to watch and right there at number
one is Love is Blind if you want to find
Rami on Hulu you have to go into the
search bar and type in Romney otherwise
that thing is never popping up not for
anyone not for never oh man all right
two great compelling arguments round
three is where our competitors found
their footing and started throwing some
Haymakers because Andrew made a great
point that you know you hear how
passionate Roxy is talking about love is
blind while she's defending Romney but
then you also have that closing
statement Rox where it's like yeah love
is blind is on Netflix you have 30
million people watching it and it may be
a little easier to find is it properly
rated I can't necessarily speak to love
his blonde as much as I can Romney
because I'm more of a fan of Rami but I
will say that love is blind feels
properly rated for people who watch it
because they know that it may not be the
the highest uh bar to pass as far as a
Show's intelligence quotient but it's
very fun you are feeding into my point
this is incredibly Blasphemous and
underrated outlook on my show I'll take
the point thank you I feel like Romney
might be a little more underrated Than
Love is Blind so Romney gets the point
but Andrew you did convince me I will
check out love is blind but do we do we
feel like season three which doesn't
have a Tomato Meter score yet and I will
say season two I think is 86 percent
season one is 66 percent so the show's
trending in the right direction but
maybe is it too many people just trying
to be famous as opposed to looking for
love
there's no more to it so let's move on
to round number four Roxy striers in
Pole Position two to one and we go to
with the best moment of the year as far
as television goes in 2022 Roxy Strayer
you have a one-point lead you could take
the match with this round I had to go
with the
and the best moment of that show is US
learning that Mark's wife is still alive
if you want to call it that we still
don't know exactly what happened we
don't have all of the pieces in Play We
End on that Cliffhanger of all
Cliffhangers as he screams out she's
alive we don't know if we're gonna get
to that point right because at we're
running against the clock this is his
any speaking his innie is on the outside
and in an episode where there are so
many things happening here right like
every single character is dealing with
their biggest moments and we're learning
that his neighbor is actually his boss
and what's gonna happen with John
Turturro and the love story
so there's all these mic drop moments
but nothing compares to learning that
your wife who you think you killed in a
car accident is actually working with
you and you're any and you can't get
that knowledge to her I mean my head
exploded I'm full of predictions
throughout the whole season I never
thought we could do that I was like
television man yeah I'm a dummy when it
comes to watching stuff and making
predictions and figuring out who done it
or what the twist is going to be so I
don't even try anymore everything
surprises me which is why it's so fun to
be the judge of this round because I get
surprised just waking up in the morning
Andrew Guy what was your most surprising
or best moment of the year so Roxy picks
a really great moment there's so many in
there and obviously I'll get to it when
I get to my rebuttal uh but with my show
it's a show that's been on for a very
very long time and honestly I really
feel like it's getting towards the end
of its run it's starting to get a little
redundant a little repetitive uh it's
handmaid's tale and and I really really
like this show I mean obviously it's
five seasons in it I'm still watching it
but what I will say is after all that
time and like I said it feels a little
redundant it feels like they're
recycling a lot of the same beats and
moments they finally kill one of the
Waterfords and it's not Arena it's Fred
and the way that it happens I remember
sitting and watching and I was just like
looking I was looking around the room I
was looking at my girlfriend I was
looking at my dog I don't know what the
reaction I was expecting to get was but
I was jaw dropped it was so brutal and
intense and it felt good it got that
evil in you out when you watched he got
ripped apart literally ripped apart by
all these handmaids that he had abused
for years and years and years and ruined
their lives to bring them to this place
and he finally gets his comeuppance no
one's there to save him he's alone in
the woods he's running he's terrified
and then like I said he literally gets
ripped piece to piece by this group of
handmaids it is the coolest most
vindicating greatest moment that I think
that show could ever have I don't think
they can ever top that moment and I
didn't think we'd ever get something
that good Five Seasons later
yeah I mean so we're basically going
after finding out somebody's actually
alive versus watching somebody brutally
lose their life so we're back to you
Roxy Strayer talking more about one of
all of our favorite shows of the Year
Severance I think that show is brilliant
I still think it's brilliant and for
years they have been torturing us I mean
truly torturing us Fred is one of the
worst people we've ever seen on
television watching myself scream at the
television get up get em was probably my
least favorite thing I've ever done that
moment made me feel awful inside because
I realized I had turned into a true
Monster based on another monster and I
think that the great things that we had
been watching was the dynamic between
them and US wondering how is he gonna
finally get it and the payoff is
wonderful and gross and horrible but now
we still have a whole show and it's just
without him and they killed my my the
biggest villain character on the show
and so I think that they they pulled
their punch a little too quick I think
that they needed to wait we've got one
more season and I know we're focusing on
Serena who's great too but we couldn't
just we couldn't just save that a little
longer so I didn't have to feel like
dirt about myself for an entire season
for rooting for that as opposed to the
best moment on Severance that I think we
can all get behind we all want these
innies to find out what happened with
their Audis we all wanted him to know
that your wife my dude the therapist in
there that's your wife come on and it
opens a lot of doors instead of closing
doors so we maybe could see this murder
of Fred of the hands made in the
handmade Tales coming more so than we
saw the twists in terms of severance but
Andrew we're just talking about the best
moment of the year it could be something
that surprised you or just could be
something that you were anticipating and
finally paid off
yeah and that's exactly what it was for
me it was this moment that I never
thought we were going to get it like
Brock said they were dangling it in
front of us for so long it's never going
to happen and now maybe they did pull
their punches a little bit too soon but
I think the other side of that coin is I
was getting tired of Fred Waterford I
was getting tired of that same thing
happening over and over so him actually
dying for me was actually kind of a
relief because I was like now we're
going to get something a little bit
different it's not just gonna be Fred
and Serena against Elizabeth Holmes like
forever we've got that for already half
a decade so I love that it actually
opened things up to just be a little bit
different now talking about Severance if
we talk like maybe the best episode of
the year like I think she wins this
conversation but I think in her initial
uh argument she kind of almost worked
against herself because this show has so
many incredible moments right like
Severance is jam-packed with so many
great things whether it's the love story
between walking and terturo or the wife
or the fact that heli is actually evil
like all of these things are so
incredible I couldn't pick a moment
between all of them whereas with
handmaid's tale it is truly the best
moment that we got all years with
Severance I'd have to sit there for an
hour in a drawing board being like man
which one of these do I actually like
more
uh pretty good range one that that
Joseph finds you know you can go from
playing Shakespeare and love to Fred
Waterford handmaid's tale uh Roxy stryer
in his final statement time and you get
the opening Salvo in round four there
are a lot of Great Moments in Severance
but this is the one this is the one that
had everybody talking and Mark I need
you to ask yourself here
are you more about death are you about
life because Drew paints a picture of
the most gruesome death in television
history horrible awful and you might be
cheering for it but it ain't pretty I'm
talking about life she's alive what a
Frankenstein moment we are about to
bring somebody who we think is dead
something we've all wanted of our loved
ones back to life and what will that
look like we don't know but this is the
moment that we know something's gonna
happen and it's gonna be interesting all
right the wife versus death is the the
way this was positive to me making my
decision but Andrew guy has the final
statement here in round four Andrew
you're supporting according to your
partner uh death Mark ask yourself this
you've gone to the Eagles versus the
commanders or Redskins Super Bowl
they've gone there seven times seven
years in a row somehow you both end up
making it to that to that that
championship game the playoff game not
the Super Bowl but every year the Eagles
beat you every single year this rivalry
has been going on for decades and
decades and then finally you get five
seven years in a row of losing to them
in the biggest game of the year but then
guess what that final season comes and
you murder the Eagles all of them are
dead this the commanders win the game
they get the ring they get the champagne
that's what it was for us in handmaid's
tale yes it was a rivalry that finally
ended the bad guy lost the good guy won
that's why it's the best moment in
television what this boils down to for
me is look seeing Mark's wife still
alive was a shocking might have been the
biggest shocking moment not just that
show but of the TV season in general but
if you're looking at where we started
with Severance we're still on season one
of severance we got a lot of twists and
turns handmaid's tale I feel like I mean
this is we're now in season five I think
it's 81 one percent that season five is
and with that season four finale you
have we've been building to this for a
long time we've been anticipating when
could this happen will it ever happen
and so I just think that that weird
tantric anticipation of it finally
happened and then it paid off and it
even made Roxy's neighbors doubt her
sanity it's it's something that you
really have to take into account and so
I will give the points to Andrew Guy
even though Mark's wife being alive I
think it gives us a lot of juiciness for
season two so uh one show starts on its
way out
just checking I chose death but again
the way Andrew said it it was death to
another team in the NFC east and not
mine so you know I had to take the
Lesser two evils there so we move on to
round at number five we do have time on
the clock so here's how it's going to
work this is the Tie break around you
each of the crew two points thus far and
now it all comes down to this as far as
the best TV of 2022 what is the best
performance that you saw all season long
now here's how we'll play it can be a
show that started in 2021 or maybe a
season that started back two years ago
and then ran through 2022 so we'll be a
little loose the interpretation here we
just want to hear some great
performances from y'all starting with
you Andrew Guy Michael Keaton and dope
sick and I had so many people out there
that I wanted to go to for this
performance because like Roxy said I do
think that TV is better now than it's
ever been there's so many incredible
actors and actresses but Keaton is a guy
that I've watched since I was a kid and
it felt like he was never gonna come
back you know in the in the late 90s
early 2000s it felt like he was just
kind of done but then he comes back into
the world with the other guys and then
he's a superstar again with Birdman and
this show it's you can tell it's near
and dear to his heart he lost his nephew
to a fentanyl heroin addiction and this
is something that when you you can see
it on the screen it is visceral this is
the thing that's happening all the time
and the fact that Keaton is able to
ground this he plays kind of like the
hapless doctor that's just trying to
help out his patience and he gets them
all addicted and then he starts to take
the blame for that and then he gets
addicted himself all of these beats and
moments that he has to go to he executes
absolutely brilliantly perfectly pulled
off it's never reaching it's never
overacting it is just real and it is raw
and for someone that's been doing it for
like my whole life to see him come out
and do a mini series on Hulu that is
this good and him maybe give the best
performance of his career
I was just blown away yeah I love how
you pointed out that you know a lot of
us who grew up with Michael Keaton
seeing him in Beetlejuice and Batman and
all these wonderful big budget
blockbuster movies then it's like he
just doesn't feel like acting anymore
it's like oh no we miss Michael Keaton
then he just has this stirring comeback
he's nominated for awards again and then
a performance like Dope Sick is
something we always knew he had in him
and wow what a just a a a a fall from
grace a attempt to return I mean that
thing takes you through the gamut of
emotions watching his character in dope
six so a high bar set Roxy star but you
have a tendency to hurt all over these
what is your best performance of 2022.
Kelly Riley in Yellowstone as Beth she
is out of this world phenomenal and I
don't understand why the entire show the
entire cast continues to get snubbed by
every single award they're never even
nominated which is crazy because it's
one of the most watched shows on TV and
she is by by Far and Away the best part
of the show which is really saying
something because she is with some big
Heavy Hitters on that show but it is
Beth we've never seen a character like
this on television I don't know how I
love her so much because she's bad like
on paper
bad person she kidnaps people she beats
the crap out of people she drinks way
too much she's verbally abusive to her
loved ones she's a loose cannon
completely but somehow this British
actress who is not oscar-nominated not
Emmy nominated just this random British
actress boy do the Brits do it right
comes in and embodies somebody so
opposite of herself in a way that is
just like
mind-blowing and I not only it's all the
things it's one of the best dramas it is
the most underrated or one of the most
underrated shows by the academy saying
but more importantly it is the best
performance of the year and it's Kelly
Riley's performance
all right two great arguments one that I
might have expected and one that I did
not but wow Yellowstone and dope sick
again two highly acclaimed shows and now
we go back to Andrew Guy and here's
where we stand we have enough time for
each one of you to have one last
rebuttal round and then I gotta make a
decision so Andrew empty the chamber the
four is yours here we go so what I will
say is that Kelly has had her chance for
half of a decade now to get any sort of
recognition from like Roxy said one of
the most watched shows and she's not
getting it and I don't know why because
I think she does a great job on that
show my parents think that she's one of
the best parts of that show but she's
not better than Michael Keaton and dope
sick he had one chance Eight Episodes to
do it and he blew everyone away and
we've seen Kelly kind of embody this
character before even if she's the
starkiness from Sherlock Holmes but when
you look at Michael Keaton's filmography
he has not really done this exact thing
before like Ella said he's done big he's
done Blockbuster he's done introspective
Birdman was a little weird but nothing
quite as real as this he won the Emmy
for a reason Kelly had her shot she's
five years five years later she's still
not gonna have it rocks I'm sorry but
Keaton will have it for dope sick and I
love you and I'm sorry Kelly we all know
the awards get political and yeah I
think awards are great I think they help
further careers all that good stuff I
don't put a lot of stock in what TV
shows I need to be watching the
performances just based on winning
Awards but it is something to note Roxy
stryer we go back to you you have the
last word in the match for the win
Michael Keaton's amazing in that show
he's so great I really wanted to throw
myself off of the building 15 times
while watching him it was like miserable
to watch him it was a truly miserable
experience that he did a great job doing
Kelly takes a miserable character and
makes me somehow feel good I've never
experienced what I'm feeling when I'm
watching her performance where I'm like
this should be in literally last night's
episode we are watching her Pummel a
girl into the ground and I'm sitting
there like this is so fun this is a
blast to watch even though it's a drama
I I think Dope Sick we have seen time
and time again people embody people who
are literally dope sick and it's
horrible and he did a great job with it
but it has been done a character like
Beth I haven't seen I we don't give
women characters like this ever but even
a man I've never even a man even anybody
we just don't see this and you're right
I don't think she is gonna get a nod
from the Emmys ever and I and surprise
surprise and Oscar nominee gets a nod
from the Emmys we've seen that before
but that has nothing to do with her
performance it's sad that she won't get
seen but she's seen by me that's what
matters most
wow and very impassioned response from
Roxy stryer and when you look at both
these shows there is some connective
tissue here because they both did both
characters I should say both struggled
with some sort of uh substance abuse in
in the process of the show and you know
for me I know Andrew sympathizes with
Michael Keaton not necessarily from the
substance abuse but also his preferred
chicken restaurant he's a big fan of
your favorite chicken sandwich of all
time so we'll go there with Michael
Keaton but I I feel like when Roxy
points out that this is a character that
we haven't seen in General on TV I mean
with Michael Keaton you'd have to go all
the way back to his performance in
something like clean and sober to really
get any sort of the vibe that we got
from him and dope sick but this was an
argument I was not anticipating I was
not expecting but hearing Roxy's support
Kelly Riley and the way that that has
sort of gone through the various arcs of
Yellowstone and her to stand out in a
show like that I think that that does
speak to the performance and so it's
doing don't do it to me
it's gonna be Yellowstone getting the
point and it's gonna be Roxy stryer
winning the match and Andrew guy we just
have to be happy that we have Michael
Keaton back in our lives on a weekly
basis with dopestick for Eight Episodes
but um
Kelly needed that one
I think I think Roxy did need that point
and so we do go to Roxy first for issue
again if Twitter's still around and all
these other wonderful social media
places where can everybody find you out
there in the world Rox yeah if you want
to know how I feel about the 115 shows I
watched I tweet about them all Roxy
stryer and like Mark said the world
girls were selling this calendar the
worldgirls.com it's so it's uh just the
best this year we did these magazine
covers it was awesome and we spend
thousands of hours on it so please go
check it out I would say your guys's man
photo shoot pictures are the greatest
thing I've ever seen they're like
absolutely laugh out loud incredible and
I'm still I was like looking I was like
huh and they're still hot you're still
hot and you're still mad
The Men's Health cover and the Rolling
Stone cover uh were were two of my
favorites from that upcoming World Girls
County you can check out right now uh
Andrew guy I'm not sure if you have a
calendar available for next year but
where can everybody find you in case you
do ah
you guys can find me drinking down the
street at my local bar because I've lost
another episode of binge battle another
one one I I knew there was no way I
could actually beat Roxy in a TV debate
but I feel like I got close you guys can
uh check me out on Twitter at Andrew Guy
um and uh way to go Rox I I loved your
choices I love also that our number one
and number two were the exact same I
think on the first two questions or
something like that I know that I also
had the rehearsal and Abbott Elementary
which would have been a lot of fun to
talk about yeah you had amazing pics
amazing pics and if it makes you feel
any better I think I'm undefeated here I
I think I am undefeated Mark we'll have
to check the tape but I will I don't
know am I a champion some might say you
you might be the 2022 champion of binge
battle and you know Andrew Guy we'd love
to have you back next year you put in 50
hours of TV viewing so I feel like you
still have some more arguments to Levy
for this program but you both have
wonderful performances in in this film
always low and it's been just crushing
it at festivals Nationwide picking up
Awards sometimes it's the best movie at
the festival and it's it's really
incredible I saw the movie you guys were
fantastic at it but it's just great to
see we talk about shows like Abbott
Elementary and and these little engines
that could always well with gaining
steam Coast to Coast here in the states
uh and just is there a way for everybody
to check it out yet is it is it did you
just follow them on social media see
where it's playing in your town that
sort of thing I'll let our award-winning
lead actress tell you where to check it
out don't say it like you're not
award-winning yourself yeah I was hoping
you'd say it Sarah yeah of course uh
right now I I have a we have a very good
feeling that it will be available for
people to see but in the meantime if you
want to know where to watch it or where
it's going always Lola film uh that's
the best place to check it out on
Instagram they keep you updated same
thing on the website which is listed on
the Instagram as well it'll tell you if
it's coming to a theater near you or how
you will be able to watch it and to the
people who already have seen it and are
saying kind things I just think that
this is Drew in my's like best we text
about it it's there's nothing better in
the world than having a dream and then
being able to live even a tiny part of
that is so cool so any support that
anybody wants to give us by actually
watching it checking it out means
everything to both me and Drew
award-winning Drew uh y'all did a
wonderful job you're both Award winners
in my book it was a banner year for
television and a banner year for Roxy
stryer and Andrew guy so thank you all
for joining us here on binge battle our
wonderful producer Christian rubalcaba
his Wonder Dog Draco and everybody here
at Rotten Tomatoes it's one big happy
family and once again for all the
waiters in the world of TV streaming
movies everything in between just head
over to rottentomatoes.com I'm Mark
Ellis and we'll see you next time right
here on binge battle
Bring It On